You've probably seen dry-ice before, but did
you know you can make it? In this project
you'll learn how to make some portable and
"on-demand" dry ice using a pillow case and
a fire extinguisher.
For this project, I picked up this CO2 fire
extinguisher from a local fire equipment servicing
company. It's a 15lb extinguisher they had
sitting in storage, and they said I could
have it for free. It even came fully charged
with 15 lbs of food grade CO2. Now these are special
extinguishers typically found in restaurant
kitchens, mechanical rooms, or rooms with
sensitive equipment like computers. You can
know they're charged with carbon dioxide by
stickers like these, or by holes punched in
the servicing label. They also tend to have
an extremely large discharge horn and no pressure
gauges. The operation is pretty simple. Just
remove the locking pin from the handle, and
squeeze down when ready. The tank is full
of liquid CO2, but it comes out as a gas and
little chunks of dry-ice snow. All the residue
quickly evaporates leaving everything as clean
as when you started. It just makes it a little
harder to breathe. Ok, now here's the trick
to making dry ice. Take a cloth bag like a
pillow case, and wrap it over the end of the
discharge horn, pulling up all the loose material,
then go ahead and give it a blast. The vapor
is really cold, and gets trapped at the bottom
of the sack. There's also some dry-ice sticking
to the discharge horn, so wipe that off as
you're pulling it out. Alright, let's see
what we got. Now it's probably a good idea
to be wearing insulated gloves when handling
dry-ice because it's -78ºC. It is extremely
cold, but I found if I move it around quickly
enough, it doesn't sit in one place long enough
to give me a frost-bite. Digging down to the
bottom of the sack you'll find larger clumps
that look something like a dry-ice snowball.
Now these are sublimating directly from a
solid to a gas, so to preserve them a little
longer I'm going to transfer them into a little
bowl like this one. This should make them
a bit more convenient to work with, as well
as keep the overall temperature low enough
to slow down the reaction. Alright, the bowl
is full, and there's our batch of dry-ice
ready for experiments. Using something like
the bottom of a glass or a jar, we can compact
the snow to make it as dense as possible,
then gently set a lid overtop. If you put
the lid on too tight, the pressure of the
gas will build and blow it off. Let's try
the classic experiment of placing a few chunks
in a container and adding some water. This
is how we get the flowing fog you'd see in
something like a halloween witches brew. This
can also be poured out for a cascading waterfall
effect. And look, there's no mess to clean
up. If we add some dry ice to a container
of warm water, and screw on a lid with a small
vent hole in it, we get a little CO2 geyser
rocketing out of the top. Shaking it will
speed up the reaction and increase it to a
pressure that could possibly be used to drive
a small motor. Well now you know how to make
dry-ice whenever you need it, as long as you've
got access to a carbon dioxide fire extinguisher.
Now making fog is great, but there are crazier
things that you can do with dry-ice that you'll
find in another project. Like making a poor
mans version of liquid nitrogen, that's cold
enough to flash freeze an orange. You'll also
see how dry-ice is used in making a tasty
batch of carbonated ice-cream. Well that's
it for now. If you liked this project, perhaps
you'll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com